my name is mark Kay I'm a professor of
pediatrics and genetics I'm Dennis ferry
family professor and I'm a vice chair
associate chair for research in the
department of pediatrics for my PhD I
studied Drosophila developmental
genetics and that's where I got
interested in in genetic diseases
thinking that and when I go back to
medical school I should do something
that's a little more applicable to
medicine I have to say that when I
started my graduate career I actually
had a strong interest in metabolism and
it was I guess when I started looking at
possible research projects I got very
interested in some of the new genetic
ideas and some of the ideas about how a
single egg could differentiate into a
whole organism and that's really when I
got interested in more developmental
genetics these discoveries that you make
and knowing that you've found something
out about nature that nobody else is
known and making a contribution to our
understanding of nature that really
nobody else is knowing or developing or
participating in the development of a
new treatment that will be useful for
treating patients who have serious
diseases I mean those two things really
keep me going
you